[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend eine
Reform der Bundeswehr hatte sich fast
jeder Bundesverteidigungsminister oder
Ministerin auf die Fahnen geschrieben
wobei die Stoßrichtungen über die
Jahrzehnte sehr unterschiedlich sein
konnte lange Zeit ging es darum die
Bundeswehr schlanker und flexibler
aufzustellen schnelle
Krisenreaktionskräfte waren das große
Thema jetzt geht's wieder in die andere
Richtung mehr Personal mehr Standorte
mehr Panzer klassische
Landesverteidigung
eines aber ist gleich geblieben das
schaffungswesen müsste unbedingt
reformiert die Bundeswehr besser
ausgerüstet und die
Ministerialbürokratie entschlackt werden
das hat Verteidigungsminister Pistorius
nun gleich als erstes ein Angriff
genommen aber wie gesagt der ist nicht
der erste der das versucht
Christiane hübscher berichtet es ist
dieses Organigramm auf das Boris
Pistorius an seinem ersten Arbeitstag im
Verteidigungsministerium blickt
unzählige graue und weiße Kästchen die
für Bonn und Berlin stehen dahinter
stecken 3000 Menschen verzweifelt
versucht der neue Minister sein Haus zu
verstehen es gelingt ihm nicht ich mache
seit über 30 Jahren Verwaltung und
politische Führung auf verschiedenen
Ebenen oder fast 30 Jahren und habe
viele Organigramme gesehen und selber
auch an ihnen gearbeitet als ich dies
sah war mir relativ schnell klar dass so
man ein so riesen Haus nicht führen kann
Pistorius zaudert nicht lange und er
fängt ganz oben an entlässt
Generalinspektor Zorn hier in der Mitte
bei seinem Zapfenstreich und beruft als
neuen ranghöchsten general Carsten
Breuer rechts im Bild
auch die Chefin des beschaffungsamtes
muss gehen aus ihrem öffentlich
gewordenen Abschiedsbrief spricht
Verbitterung das Amt sei nahezu immer
der Prügelknabe wenn Beschaffung
angeblich nicht läuft keine Entlassungen
im großen Stil hat Pistorius heute auf
einer Personalversammlung versprochen
dennoch dürfte es auch Widerstand geben
ich finde ein Minister der derart
einschneidende Maßnahmen ergreift muss
begründen was diejenigen die abgelöst
werden falsch gemacht haben sollen dazu
habe ich nichts gehört was hat er
bisherige Generalinspektor falsch
gemacht das wusste ich gerne ich finde
es richtig wir leben in einer
zeitenwände die muss auch bei der
Bundeswehr vor allen Dingen bei den
Offizieren eben
Verteidigungsministerium ankommen zu
glauben der Minister kommt und geht wir
bleiben ich glaube das soll sie sich
jeder jetzt mal Abschminken noch einen
General soll einziehen in der Leitung im
Bendlerblock als Chef des neuen Planungs
und führungs- Christian freuding bisher
kriegserklärer im Ukraine Lagezentrum
daran gibt es auch Kritik ich frage mich
wer den Minister beraten hat oder ob er
auch zivilen zivilenrat eingeholt hat
weil das wir nicht brauchen ist eine
zusätzliche militärische Führung des
Ministeriums das ist die vornehmer
Aufgabe der zivilen Staatssekretäre
keine 100 Tage dauert die düstere
Bestandsaufnahme des Boris Pistorius der
Bundeswehr fehlt es an allem vom
Unterhemd bis zur Panzerhaubitze soweit
so bekannt er braucht Geld viel mehr als
die 100 Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen
verlangt der heute wieder im Bundestag
in seinem Haus aber herrscht
Zuständigkeit Chaos
wenn aber die Leute gut sind und die
Ergebnisse nicht dazu passen dann kann
es nicht an den Leuten liegen sondern an
den Strukturen in den Abläufen also muss
ich die Abläufe anfassen damit die
Ergebnisse besser werden und das ist das
gemeinsame Ziel aus dem Stand zum
beliebt mehr werden sagt Boris Pistorius
er sei 63 und am Ziel nur erfolgreich
muss seine Reformen
und es sind ja gleich mehrere Baustellen
Strukturen in Ministerium und Bundeswehr
reformieren die Streitkräfte besser
ausrüsten und gleichzeitig noch die
Ukraine unterstützen während man in Kiew
bereits über die aktuellen Kämpfe hinaus
denkt denn auch wenn es den Ukrainern
gelingt die Russen dieses Mal
zurückzudrängen oder zumindest
aufzuhalten bleibt ja die Frage wie sich
das Land in Zukunft davor schützen kann
immer wieder aufs Neue angegriffen zu
werden Russland macht aus seinen
imperialen eroberungsansprüchen mehr
der Wunsch der Ukraine in die NATO
aufgenommen zu werden schien bislang
wenig realistisch doch beim Besuch von
Nato-Generalsekretär Jens solltenberg
heute in Kiew in klang das etwas anders
Florian
Bericht diesen Platz in Kiel haben sich
schon viele aus dem Westen zeigen lassen
die zerstörten russischen Panzer die die
Ukraine ausstellt als habe sie den Krieg
bereits gewonnen nur einer war bisher
nicht da seitdem der Krieg begonnen hat
und so ist allein die Ankunft von Jens
Stoltenberg heute ein Symbol selbst der
meist so abgebrühte ukrainische
Präsident selenski wirkt
wir sehen das als Zeichen als Zeichen
dass die NATO bereit ist ein neues
Kapitel zu eröffnen die Ukraine will in
die NATO wie sehr zeigen solche Bilder
auf dem Europaplatz in Kiew thront über
allem das Emblem der NATO nur will oder
wollte die bisher nicht dass die Ukraine
schnell Beitritt 2008 auf dem Gipfel in
Bukarest vertröstet man das Land auf
irgendwann vor allem auf Drängen der
damaligen deutschen Kanzlerin dann kam
der Krieg ein Beitritt schien
unwahrscheinlicher denn je als wohl oder
mir selenski im Herbst einen neuen NATO
Beitrittsantrag stellte wollten viele in
der Allianz sein liebsten gar nicht
darüber reden nur aus Europäer drängen
auf einer Perspektive wie Hotels
ehemaliger Oberbefehlshaber der ist
nicht
die sind heute schon ein NATO Armee und
aus auch die das ganze Gedankengut ist
sehr westlich von aber Wertegemeinschaft
unsere Wertegemeinschaft insoweit bin
ich fest überzeugt dass wir Ukraine
einnehmen müssen in die EU und NATO und
dann Auftritt deutenberg in Kiew was er
sagt ist nicht neu aufhorchen lässt was
er weglässt und zwar jede Einschränkung
bei dieser Aussage
um es klar zu sagen der Ukraine steht
ein Platz in der Euro atlantischen
Familie zu der Platz der Ukraine ist in
der NATO
place ist in noto ein möglicher Beitritt
werde das Top-Thema beim Nato-Gipfel in
vilius im Juli was im Kreml für
erwartbar heftigen Widerstand sorgt
ein NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine so
putinsprecher peschkov wäre eine ernste
bedeutende Gefahr für Russland und seine
Sicherheit
ernst ist derzeit aber weiter vor allem
eines der Angriff Russlands auf die
Ukraine der allein wohl die Ukraine in
die Arme der NATO treibt
sondern noch vertiefen so
Korrespondenten in Brüssel Florian
Neuhann inwieweit sind das tatsächlich
neue Töne die Stoltenberg da heute in
Kiew anschlug
nein der Sache ist das nicht wirklich
neu aber der Tonfall der ist wirklich
ein anderer sehr viel verbindlicher als
ich es deutenberg dazu in den letzten
Monaten hier jemals erlebt habe und was
vor allem neu ist ist das die NATO
erstmals wirklich offensiv über dieses
Thema den NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine auch
reden möchte ich erinnere mich an den
letzten NATO Außenminister ist das
Treffen der NATO Außenminister in
Bukarest in Rumänien im letzten November
da wollte der ukrainische Außenminister
den NATO-Beitritt offensiv zum Thema
machen aber stieß weitgehend auf taube
Ohren vor allem aus West Europa da hieß
es dass er doch jetzt wirklich kein
Thema das sei bestenfalls eine Frage für
die ja irgendwann ferne Zukunft insofern
gibt es halt wirklich einen Wandel in
der Kommunikation zu beobachten aber
noch mal klar ist dass dieser Beitritt
jetzt keinesfalls morgen oder in diesem
Jahr demnächst ansteht ja das Problem
ist ja auch so lange landen einen
territorialen Konflikt verwickelt ist
ist eine Aufnahme die NATO doch schwer
vorstellbar und das weiß natürlich auch
Putin und sorgt ja auch dafür dass
dieser Zustand nicht aufhört
an der Tat sollte die NATO die Ukraine
jetzt aufnehmen dann wäre sie also
sofort Kriegspartei und stünde damit
auch Russland gegenüber der Atommacht
und das will man natürlich auf jeden
Fall vermeiden und insofern geht es in
der echten Diskussion hier in Brüssel
vor allem eigentlich um Alternativen zur
NATO-Mitgliedschaft um die Frage was man
stattdessen eben anbieten kann und da
geht es etwa um einen größeres
Unterstützungspaket für die ukrainische
Armee von Seiten der NATO oder auch um
die Frage von Sicherheitsgarantien die
einzelne große NATO-Staaten gegenüber
der Ukraine aussprechen können für die
Zukunft alles sozusagen auf dem Weg hin
zur Mitgliedschaft aber keine
Sicherheitsgarantie kann jemals so viel
wert sein wie der berühmte Artikel 5 der
NATO also diese Bündnis Verpflichtung im
Fall eines Angriffs auch dem Land
beizustehen insofern wird die Ukraine
hier nicht locker lassen und mein
Eindruck ist dass sie dafür für ihren
Weg in die NATO heute ein bisschen mehr
Sympathien und Zustimmung auch aus der
Allianz selbst erfährt danke für die
Einschätzung Florian
der Ukraine Krieg die Rolle Deutschlands
und auch die Situation der Bundeswehr
sind auch die Themen nachher bei Maybrit
Illner zu deren Gästen unter anderem der
Bundesverteidigungsminister gehört
Bundeskanzler Scholz würde die
warburg-affäre wohl gerne loswerden aber
das wird die Opposition zu verhindern
versuchen sie ist und bleibt eine offene
Flanke des Kanzlers weil die
Erinnerungslücken die er da immer wieder
geltend machte auf seine Kritiker wenig
glaubwürdig wirken
zugute kam ihm bisher dass diese
Vorgänger aus seiner Hamburger Zeit
ziemlich sperrig zu vermitteln und
Begriffe wie cum-ex-geschäfte für ein
breites Publikum eher schwer verdaulich
sind
unterm Strich geht es um die Frage ob
Olaf Scholz irgendeinen Einfluss darauf
hatte dass der Hamburger Warburg Bank
Steuerrückzahlungen zunächst erlassen
wurden die Unionsfraktion im Bundestag
will die Untersuchung dieser Affäre
jetzt noch mal neu aufrollen Daniel
[__] Bericht
der kanzlerstuhl bleibt heute morgen
leer kürzlich war Olaf Scholz auch hier
schon zum Thema Warburg befragt worden
seine Antworten da aus sich der
Opposition und zu reichen in der
kanzlerbefragung fand er es noch
besonders cool dass er um unsere Fragen
locker drumherum geschwurmelt ist ich
sage das so deutlich so war es nämlich
und deswegen gibt es nur einen Weg
dieses Thema jetzt sorgfältig zu
untersuchen nämlich die Einsetzung eines
Untersuchungsausschusses
zum Hintergrund zu 14 erklärt der
Bundesfinanzhof cum-ex-geschäfte für
illegal zu 16 soll die Warburg Bank
dementsprechend 47 Millionen Euro ans
Finanzamt zurückzahlen dann gibt es
mehrere Treffen von Warburg und
SPD-Vertretern unter anderem von
Bürgermeister Scholz und Bankchef
olearius der zu einem der Treffen ein
Papier mitbringt das gegen eine
rückzahlungargumentiert
wenig später so ein Tagebucheintrag des
Bankiers aber Scholz ihn angerufen und
gesagt er möge das Papier an
Finanzsenator tschechische schicken das
habe er getan gut eine Woche später
entscheidet das Finanzamt das changers
Behörde direkt untersteht auf die
Rückzahlung verzichte man nun
in Hamburg wurde hier zuvor gut zwei
Jahren bereits ein
Untersuchungsausschuss eingesetzt im
Bund braucht es daher keinen weiteren
sagt die SPD es gab keine Verfehlungen
der zuständigen Hamburger Behörden es
gab keine politische Einflussnahme das
ist offensichtlich der cdu/cs so geht es
nicht um Erkenntnis gewinnen sondern
reine Stimmungsmache gegen den
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz ein
bundestagsuntersuchungsausschuss habe
mehr Kompetenzen als der in Hamburg hält
die Union entgegen und erhält
Unterstützung von der Linken beide
verweisen darauf dass Scholz im
Finanzausschuss 220 zunächst sehr
Konkretes aus sagte zu einem Treffen mit
Warburg
und sich erst bei späteren Befragungen
nicht mehr habe erinnern können
insofern hatte die grüne finanzpolitikin
Lisa Paus Recht die Scholz wegen dieser
Erinnerungslücken eben auch der Lüge
bezichtigt hat Pauls trieb die
Aufklärung damals maßgeblich voran auch
mit Hilfe der FDP inzwischen ist sie
Familienministerin und auch die FDP Teil
des Kabinett Scholz beide Fraktionen
haben an dem Untersuchungsausschuss
jetzt kein Interesse Aufklärung ja was
wir aber nicht benötigen sind zwei
Ausschüsse in der gleichen Sache lassen
Sie doch die Hamburger Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ihre Arbeit machen der
erwartete inhaltliche Mehrwert mit
dieser engen auf Hamburg beschränkten
Fragestellungen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
ist stark begründungswürdig nötig für
das Einsetzen eines
Untersuchungsausschusses sind 25% der
Abgeordneten die hat die Union allein
entschieden wird darüber nun im
Geschäftsordnungsausschuss
voraussichtlich im Mai
und jetzt gibt es erstmal andere
Nachrichten des Tages von Heinz Wolf
heute hat es an einigen deutschen
Flughäfen bereits Warnstreiks gegeben ab
3 Uhr nachts folgt der Bahnverkehr am
Hamburger Flughafen sind bis
einschließlich Freitag alle Abflüge
gestrichen betroffen sind auch die
Flughäfen in Düsseldorf und Köln-Bonn ab
morgen folgen Flughafen Stuttgart und
bundesweite Streiks bei der Bahn bis 13
Uhr fahren keine Fernzüge auch der
Regionalverkehr fällt weitestgehend aus
die Bundesregierung hat Pläne für einen
am Standort Rügen geplantes flüssig
erdgasterminal verteidigt Bundeskanzler
scholz sagte am Abend nach einer
Gesprächsrunde zu dem Thema in Binz man
brauche auch im Osten Deutschlands
Import Infrastruktur die Pläne sorgen
seit Monaten für heftigen Widerstand auf
der Insel und so hatten sich bis zur
Ankunft von Scholz und
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck laut Polizei
bis zu 600 Demonstranten versammelt auch
die Schweriner Landesregierung hatte
Zweifel angemeldet ob das Terminal
überhaupt benötigt wird
Menschen mit Behinderungen sollen mehr
Chancen erhalten einen Job auch
außerhalb von speziellen Werkstätten zu
bekommen einen entsprechendes Gesetz hat
nun der Bundestag beschlossen um das
Ziel zu erreichen soll unter anderem die
Ausgleichsabgabe erhöht werden sie wird
für Betriebe fällig die nicht genügend
Menschen mit Behinderungen beschäftigen
Firmen mit mehr als 60 Arbeitsplätzen
müssen mindestens 5% ihrer Jobs
bereitstellen
im ukrainischen Mario Paul entstand
Anfang März 2022 ein Foto das weltweit
Menschen erschüttert hat und dass eine
Jury jetzt als world pressfoto
ausgewählt hat das Foto aufgenommen hat
der Ukraine
Irina kalilina vier Männer tragen sie
aus einer zerstörten Klinik in mariopol
ihr Baby wird tot zur Welt gebracht eine
halbe Stunde später stirbt auch die
Mutter das Bild so die Jury symbolisiere
den Schrecken des Krieges für die
Zivilbevölkerung
UN-Generalsekretär gutärisch hat eine
Waffenruhe von zunächst mindestens drei
Tagen im Sudan gefordert die UNO stehen
mit den Konfliktparteien in Kontakt bei
den seit Samstag andauernden Gefechten
sind nach Angaben der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation mehr als 330
Menschen getötet und fast 3.200 verletzt
worden Hintergrund der
Auseinandersetzungen ist ein Machtkampf
zwischen dem Befehlshaber der Armee und
dem Kommandanten einer paramilitärischen
Gruppierung
eigentlich ist die Lage ja klar das
Fortschreiten des Klimawandels wird nun
wirklich von Wissenschaftlern weltweit
immer und immer wieder eindringlich
dokumentiert und trotzdem ist es dann
wieder eindrücklich wenn wieder neue
Zahlen veröffentlicht werden so wie
heute vom europäischen
Informationsdienst Kopernikus der gleich
eine ganze Reihe von Rekorden auflistet
demnach erlebte Europa im letzten Jahr
den wärmsten jemals gemessenen Sommer
und die Temperaturen steigen in Europa
doppelt so stark wie im globalen
Durchschnitt
längst sind das keine abstrakten Größen
mehr sondern sichtbar und fühlbar in
Südeuropa können sie nur hoffen dass
nach der winterdürre wenigstens jetzt im
Frühling mehr Regen fällt hoffen und
beten
Christian Rechenberg berichtet
der Himmel muss jetzt helfen in
lesbuniola in Katalonien tragen die
Bauern ihre Madonna über ein
verdurstetes Land und sie beten für
Regen es ist ihre einzige das ist ihre
letzte Hoffnung
wir gehen gar nicht normalerweise regnet
es im Herbst ja immer etwas aber in
Teilen Kataloniens haben wir seit
letztem früh
vom Herrgott verlassen fühlen sie sich
auch am Gardasee noch nie war das Wasser
so niedrig die Insel San Biagio ist
keine mehr das Paradies trocknet aus und
zwischen Frankreich und Spanien brennen
die Wälder es ist nicht Hochsommer es
ist april und das letzte Jahr war schon
das zweite und zwei trockenste seit
Beginn der Wetteraufzeichnungen
wir sind natürlich so ein bisschen
überrascht von der Tatsache dass wir
dass wir dass wir so schnell im Prinzip
diese Art von Temperaturanomalien sieht
extrem ja 2022 das achte in Folge der
klimaberichter Alarmsignale heißester
Sommer aller Zeiten in Europa lange
Hitzeperioden wenig Niederschlag die
Gletscher schmelzen rasant Emissionen
durch Waldbrände über den Durchschnitt
und die Gesundheit leidet messbar
ein Großteil davon auf Hitzestress
zurückzuführen
auch die Flüsse haben Stress und
diejenigen die sie brauchen als
Transportweg zum Bewässern oder zum
Kühlen von Kraftwerken zwei Drittel
aller Flüsse in Europa waren betroffen
rot steht für zu wenig Wasser
schlimmster Monat der August
und dort wo Kälte eine lebenswichtige
Rolle spielt steigen die Temperaturen im
September war es in Grönland bis zu 8°c
8 Grad in Grönland an der Oberfläche ist
katastrophal das muss man so sagen dann
haben wir ganz massives Abschmelzen der
der Schneeschichten also der oberen
Schneeschichten und was das bedeutet ist
natürlich dass wenn man das was an
Wasser gespeichert ist auf Grünland im
Prinzip in den Ozean fließt und damit
zum Anstieg des Meeresspiegels führt das
ist bemerkenswert das ist keine
Schwankung im Klimasystem das ist
wirklich ein Zeichen eine direkte Folge
der globalen Erwärmung
und so hoffen in Katalonien die einen
auf ein Wunder die anderen vertrauen
ihrem Glauben beides wird nicht genügend
sagen Experten die Menschen müssen
konkret handeln weniger Treibhausgase
verursachen und sich den neuen
Klimabedingungen anpassen
irgendwie
in welchem Tempo und Ausmaß Gebäude
umgerüstet und vor allem das Heizen auf
klimafreundlichere Methoden umgestellt
werden soll ist hierzulande ja eines der
großen Diskussionsthemen dieser Tage
daneben bleibt aber noch ein anderes
Thema der Wohnungsmangel jährlich
400.000 neue Wohnungen hatte die neue
Bundesregierung bei Amtsantritt
vollmundig zum Ziel erklärt so wie es im
Moment aussieht kann man wohl eher froh
sein wenn in den nächsten Jahren
überhaupt noch in nennenswerten Umfang
gebaut wird ein wohnungsbautag in Berlin
klagten die Verbände über einen massiven
Einbruch bei Neubauprojekten selbst
bereits genehmigte Vorhaben würden
storniert wenn die Politik gegensteuern
wolle müsse sie ihre Fördergelder massiv
aufstocken
dann sind wir auch fragen wir unsere
wirtschaftsfachfrau Valerie Haller das
sind den Ballungszentren nicht genug
gebaut wird das ist ja jetzt erstmal
nicht so neu aber dieser Einbruch jetzt
wo liegen da die Hauptursachen ja also
die Hauptursache schlechthin ist das
Bauen deutlich teurer geworden ist und
sich kaum mehr rentiert vor allem durch
die höheren Zinsen aber auch die Kosten
für Baustoffe und Grund haben noch mal
kräftig angezogen und durch die hohe
Inflation sinken auch die reale
Einkommen viele Bauherren also bekommen
kalte Füße und infolgedessen gehen die
Baugenehmigungen zurück und selbst bei
genehmigten Projekten hat bei mehr als
einem Drittel noch nicht einmal der roba
begonnen und neue Zahlen vom
ifo-Institut unterstreichen das auch
demnach werden viele Bauvorhaben derzeit
verschoben oder gestrichen ein Trend der
sich seit Monaten verschärft und
Baubetriebe zunehmend unter Druck setzt
und dann die Politik richtet sich der
Vorwurf sie tun oder nicht genug um
gegenzusteuern ja die großen
immobilienverbände wollen mehr
Fördergelder beschleunigte
Baugenehmigungen und landesweit
einheitlichere Auflagen insgesamt also
weniger Bürokratie weil die
Bauwirtschaft sagt auch das kann wohnen
wieder bezahlbar machen beim Thema Geld
macht die Bundes die bauministerin den
Verbänden wenig Hoffnung sie hält die
schon beschlossenen milliardenprogramme
für ausreichend also von den 400.000
neuen Wohnungen jährlich wie sie die
Bundesregierung an peilt spricht aktuell
keiner mehr
danke Valerie neue Wohnungen zu bauen
ist das eine daneben gibt es aber ja
auch Bemühungen bereits bestehendes
auszubauen und da gibt es durchaus
kreative Ideen die weit über das
ausgebaute Dachgeschoss hinausgehen etwa
auf Parkhäusern oder den Flachbauten von
Supermärkten Wohnungen obendrauf zu
setzen oder ehemalige Bürogebäude
umzubauen beispiele für solche
Großprojekte zeigen Oliver Heuchert und
Benjamin Dieterle
mit diesen Stahlstreben Flechten
Eisenbieger neue Balkone an ein altes
Bürohaus der ehemalige telekom-turm in
Konstanz wird zum Wohngebäude umgebaut
auf 15 Stockwerken entstehen rund 100
Eigentumswohnungen teilweise mit Blick
auf den Bodensee der aktuelle Stand ist
der dass wir im Moment in dem Ober
mitten drin sind wir heute die Ebenen 6
Betonieren mit der neuen Balkonen wir
bis zum Jahresende diese Bauarbeiten
abschließen wollen um dann mit dem
Innenausbau zu beginnen und bis im Laufe
des Jahres 2025 den Bewohnern ihre neuen
Wohnungen übergeben zu können
in diesen Räumen haben einmal rund 500
Menschen für Post und Telekom gearbeitet
das Gebäude fürs Wohnen umzubauen hilft
dem Klima
die spare mir sehr sehr viel Ressourcen
in so einem Fall ist es mal ganz viel
Beton ganz viel Stahl der schon einmal
verbaut wurde und der Charme an so eine
Baumaßnahme ist natürlich auch der dass
diese Räume sehr hoch sind dass ich ganz
tolle wohngefühle habe und Lebensgefühle
in großen hohen Räumen zwar ist vom
telekom-turm nur der Rohbau stehen
geblieben aber darauf kommt es an denn
Stahlbeton neu herzustellen verursacht
enorm viel Kohlendioxid diese Emissionen
spart ein Umbau jetzt müssen wir jeweils
projektbezogen betrachten wie viel man
einsparen kann in dem Projekt gehen wir
davon aus dass wir über 2200 Tonnen CO2
einsparen können durch den Erhalt des
Tons Projekte wie hier in Konstanz sind
nicht häufig aber sie fallen auf
2010 schon wurde in Frankfurt am Main
ein früheres Gebäude der IG Metall zum
Wohnhaus umgebaut in Düsseldorf wurde
2016 aus der Thyssen bürozentrale der
living circle
2017 entstand in Köln dieser Wohnkomplex
aus der Zentrale des Bundesverbands der
deutschen Industrie die drei
Hauptvorteile bei der Umwandlung sind
erstens ich habe es mit von einer
Bausubstanz zu tun die ich nicht neu
errichten muss der Rohbau und viele
andere Dinge sind da zweitens die
Infrastruktur ist häufig da und
Infrastruktur heißt die Erschließung
Treppenhaus Aufzugsschacht die
Tiefgarage und ähnliche Dinge und
drittens es ist kostenmäßig häufig
deutlich günstiger als ein Neubau zu
errichten oder gar alten Wohnraum zu
neuem um zu nutzen die Fachleute haben
die Kosten verschiedene Bauprojekte
verglichen als billigsten Weg ermitteln
Sie den Umbau von Büroflächen in
Wohnraum
aber auch in Konstanz war die Umwandlung
kein Selbstläufer die Planungen waren
sehr aufwendig eine Umwandlung stellt
die Beteiligten vor ganz neue
Herausforderungen nicht zuletzt das
Baurecht stellt häufig eine Hürde da
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter Hans die corona-pandemie und auch
impfskepsis haben nach Angaben von
UNICEF dazu geführt das weltweit weniger
Kinder wichtige Schutzimpfungen etwa
gegen Masern und Kinderlähmung bekommen
haben besonders betroffen ist Afrika
aber laut Unicef ist in insgesamt 112
Ländern das Niveau des Impfschutzes
gesunken zwischen 2019 und 2021 sein
rund 67 Millionen Kinder gar nicht oder
nur teilweise geimpft worden
in Texas war es heute soweit das größte
je gebaute raketensystems Starship Hop
zu einem unbemannten Testflug ab der
endete allerdings bereits kurz nach dem
Start
nach knapp vier Minuten Flug die Rakete
taumelt sichtbar eigentlich sollte sich
jetzt die Raumfähre von der Trägerrakete
lösen wegen der Probleme bringt SpaceX
die Starship Rakete in 29 km Höhe zur
Explosion SpaceX Gründer Elon Musk wirkt
dennoch nicht allzu enttäuscht kurz
zuvor 33 Triebwerke schieben die
gigantische Rakete nach oben der Staat
ist geglückt und allein das schon ist
für die Raumfahrt ein Erfolg
so arbeitet Basics sie machen und machen
bis es irgendwann funktioniert sie sind
gut durch den Staat gekommen mit dieser
riesigen monsterrakete das ist schon
eine Errungenschaft es ist noch ein
weiter Weg aber das ist ein guter Anfang
die Rakete besteht aus zwei Stufen der
weiße ist super heavy Booster Antrieb
und oben das riesige Starship 50 m hoch
mit Platz für eine Besatzung und für
mehr als 100 Tonnen Fracht eins soll die
Raumfähre Menschen auf den Mond und den
Mars bringen
Starship soll im All betankt werden und
die erste orbitalrakete seien die landen
und wiederverwendet werden kann es soll
die Raumfahrt revolutionieren Starship
ist gespickt mit Sensoren die Daten
werden Aufschluss darüber geben woran
der Testflug gescheitert ist und so
können schon in einigen Monaten
raumfahrt-fans hier den nächsten Staat
versucht bestaunen
das war es von uns weiter geht es gleich
wie schon angekündigt bei Maybrit Illner
und erst kommt aber natürlich noch das
Wetter und um 0 Uhr meldet sich dann
also in gökte mir mit unserem heute
schnell Update auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter im heute
veröffentlichten klimabberichte des
europäischen
kopernikusprogramms sind ja auch die
Arktis und Grönland ein wichtiges Thema
ja für Jahr verschwinden dort gewaltige
Eismassen nicht nur an den Rändern auch
von ganz oben her bilden sich
Wassertempel die dunkler sind dieses
Schmelzwasser nimmt wiederum leichter
Wärme auf und führt zu weiterer
Abschmelzung so frisst sich das wärmere
Wasser in das Eis hinein und fließt
unter dem Eis weiter Richtung Ozean
Schrumpf der Eispanzer weiter ist der
Prozess nicht mehr umkehrbar dieser
komplette Eisverlust dauert allerdings
ich Jahrtausende da der ursprüngliche
Zustand aber nicht wieder hergestellt
werden kann wird es als Kipppunkt
bezeichnet
und dieses geschmolzene Wasser hat
selbstverständlich Auswirkungen auf den
Ozean und auf die Atmosphäre und
letztendlich auf das Wetter schauen wir
auf das Wetter und da haben wir es mit
diesem Kringel zu tun es ist ein
Höhentief was sich langsam nach Westen
ausdehnt und es gibt Regen und zwar
kräftigen von Nordrhein-Westfalen bis an
die Alpen nach Osten hin ist es
trockenen Stern klar bei Temperaturen
von 0 Grad im Südwestdeutschlands und 9
Grad am Niederrhein das ist die
Temperaturspanne Morgen viel
Sonnenschein nach Norden und Osten hin
im Südwesten brodelt ist im Tagesverlauf
hier bin sich dann Schauer und Gewitter
das bei Temperaturen bis 20 Grad im
Nordwesten und 14 Grad am kühlsten an
der Ostsee die nächsten Tage ja am
Samstag gibt's im Osten viel
Sonnenschein im Westen Gewitter und es
wird wärmer allerdings ab Sonntag
durchwachsener ein schöner Abend